Hi there.
Welcome to our course on
deploying a Hadoop cluster.
I'm Mat Leonard,
I'll be your instructor.
These days companies collect massive
amounts of data, hundreds and
thousands of terabytes.
Analyzing terabytes of data on one
computer is practically impossible.
One simple analysis
job could take hours.
A different approach is to spread
the data over a cluster of computers and
analyze it in parallel with Hadoop and
Map Reduce.
In this first lesson,
you'll deploy a simple hadoop cluster.
You wouldn't actually use this cluster
in a real production setting, but
it will help you understand
the Hadoop architecture.
In later lessons, you'll use automated
methods to deploy larger clusters,
like you'd use in production.
To complete this course, you'll need
a basic understanding of Hadoop and
HDFS, and
be able to write MapReduce programs.
If you don't know about these,
take our excellent Intro to
Hadoop course, then return here.
Also you'll need to use Shell
commands such as SSH and
no terminal editor such as vim or nano.
You can learn about these
in our command line course.
Okay, let's get started.